if you haven't heard and it's all over
Jon Jones is out of his title fight at
Mat Square Garden with Stipe it's not
happening Jon Jones tore his pack the
UFC said minimum eight months minimum
UFC missed the boat on this a little bit
not stripp him of the belt when he beat
sarl Gan he's the heavyweight champ when
your Champ's out at least a year with
this injury there should not be a interm
title fight it should just be the vacant
B when you think about Jon Jones and
Stipe I guess the rumor anybody who's
close to the game knows that the plan
was for both these guys to retire so
either way even if their fight were to
go down like it was supposed to in two
weeks you still don't really have a
heavyweight champion so they announced
Tom Aspen versus Sergey pavlovich and
it's for an interterm heavyweight title
that should be just for the straight up
vacant World title fight